you want the whole blueprint it's like  no no just take the first yeah  and that's exactly what happened to me I  started writing these things I didn't I  knew I was going to run out of content I  didn't know what I was going to say  after that and  and I just had that message inside just  just write what you know now and then  you'll figure out what to say next right  yeah you have this quote something about  um that's profound something about how  uh the next steps aren't revealed until  you take the first step and I think  we're all victims to one degree or  another of of analysis paralysis we want  us we want to know what the map looks  like in its entirety before we even  begin and so we never get out of the  Starting Gate and I know this all the  things that I've created started with  taking a step and having no idea where  it would head